[Applause]
what's the name honey they do how's your
night going Victor
it's been the best night of my life I
need to talk to you about the episode
when Victor goes to New York because it
was my favorite of the season it was so
great so just first of all tell me your
reaction when you read that script I was
so soaked like when they're like yeah
like you know we want to do like a
things that kind of base in New York I
was so stoked like Oh whole family's
from New York um so obviously it you
know might be like one of my favorite
places in the world but that's fine
and like the way that they did it was so
well done and I was just I was really
excited to be like part of that oh so
excited me too
it's all good it's New York nobody gets
Jessamine and getting to interact with
Kinyon and Nick and and getting to have
that crossover what was that like for
you it was honestly beyond incredible I
I think he was like an amazing amazing
amazing opportunity to meet key and and
and to meet Nick like Keon was
unbelievably nice to me and really
offered me like a great perspective and
in kind of like passed the torch so to
speak in same when I finally met Nick
like we met on the last day of shooting
and so when I met him he was like was so
unbelievably nice to me and we ate
together and everything he's such a cool
guy well and I love that you said pass
the torch because in reality we got
passing of the jacket
cuz it always as cold in New York
they're a little something to remember
your weekend in the city Victor now has
Simon's iconic jacket was that always in
the script like break that moment down
for me I don't think that was planned
originally until we got the script and I
was like oh my gosh like I didn't know
about it I was like oh my gosh this is
so cool
and then when I finally got the jacket
they're like yeah this is the actual
jacket from the movie I was so stoked
like I was like no way this is so cool
I'm wearing two real cheap I was just
totally like geeking out was it one of
the ones from the movie or did they have
in the original movie like I was so so
excited also Bram said that he would
burn it if I wore it one more time do
you think we could expect to see if neat
fingers crossed
get more seasons of love Victor we could
expect to see more crossovers and if so
who would you like to see that your
interact to it okay this is like a
personal thing I would really love to
act with Jennifer Garner you know but I
think also in the same token you know
like I really want to see how the
universe expands and like how much more
the show grows and what we you know what
other issues that we tackled with the
show that's what I'm really excited to
see more than anything I would also love
to see Kathryn Langford just walk into
your coffee shop just even for a little
bit of a cameo
Ricky - yo me freaking - I would love
that one of the most gut-wrenching
moments of love Simon was when of course
he was outed without his consent to the
entire school so naturally when I was
watching the dance episode and I saw
that Andrew overheard Victor and Benji's
conversation I was having a panic attack
that we were going to have this exact
same moment happen
you can tell everyone no I would never
do that what did that mean for you to be
able to see that we had that kind of
change in love Victor first off it
showed an amazing character arc and
Andrew because in the beginning of the
season he wasn't like that he definitely
probably would have outed me I think
that it was great that we didn't go down
the same exact path and that we saw that
Victor kind of you know out of himself
in an accidental way so yeah seeing
Victor's coming out seeing - Felix was
so wonderful and like Victor said like
that was pretty darn near close to
perfect what was it like for you to film
that scene and what did you think of the
fact that Felix was the first person
that he really kind of truly came out -
I was so excited to film that scene man
he's an incredible actor I remember like
afterwards me and him were just like
hugging each other because they were
just like so much loved you know like we
just had so much love for each other and
like he did an amazing job and just like
totally being the best best friend in
the whole entire world like I think that
everyone needs a friend like Felix for
sure and then because of Benji and
Victor's chat at the dance Victor then
went home and was prepared to say those
two words mom dad I'm gay what did that
moment mean to you that was Victor
finally coming into his own and that
starts his that now he has discovered
who he is but now it's like the
explanation of exploration exploration
if I could say the very exploration of
like discovering the rest of who he is
and you know now we see how he navigates
the world once he has come out and I
can't wait to see what season two has to
hold that what would you personally like
to see in season two I would really like
to see what happens to the family
dynamic I would really like to see how
Victor and Benji's relationship grows
and flourishes
have you given any thought to Victor and
Benjy shift name would it be like vengi
or empty or would be victor victor or
sometimes they do like last name
combinations like so would that be Louis
I don't remember his last name like
Benjy like Victor or or Len G yeah
that's so funny I just loved the fact
that Benjy now gets to do those romantic
moments because that's something that he
wasn't able to do in his past
relationship and when he was on stage
and saying like the slow down version of
call me maybe that was so sweet I
honestly am just really excited to see
what they have in store and like I can't
wait to see how Benji's character
develops and how Victor develops and
what happens with the family like oh my
gosh the family we're separating just
for now after what we've been through
this year we just needed to take a
breather what do you think we can expect
to see from them moving forward I
honestly want to see what they wind up
doing with that because I don't want to
say it but you know I mean it is
spoilery so we can't say but you know
you know but like there was the betrayal
of trust between them and ultimately I
feel like sometimes time apart helps
heal everything and I think in this case
scenario they do need time apart we
don't really notice 'silly if they will
get back together like they were
highschool sweethearts
people grow apart and that's completely
normal and I really can't wait to see
what winds up happening between there
if season one for Victor was about
self-discovery and self-acceptance what
do you think season two would be about
see the two would be the way that Victor
continuously navigates through the world
after having discovered who he is
completely and accepting it I hope that
we'll still see him DMing Simon for some
advice me too me too I hope so
do you think those are on Instagram DMS
I was wondering this yeah most of them
are like Instagram DM some of them are
emails um I don't think you ever
to him though I assume he's got his
digits now he's got his iconic jacket
exactly exactly like he has to
[Music]